fundada por colonos franceses hace más
de 300 años Nueva Orleans está amenazada
por fenómenos meteorológicos extremos
para protegerse de Los Huracanes la
ciudad invirtió 14.500 millones de
dólares en un nuevo sistema de diques
claro no es un sistema 100% Perfecto es
un sistema de reducción de riesgos el
cambio climático hace que todos los
lugares del sur de Luisiana sean
vulnerables la ciudad ahora Está rodeada
por un muro de 560 kilómetros de largo y
8 metros de alto el sistema sobrevivió a
su gran primera prueba en 2021 con el
huracán Aída
los diques necesitan mantenimiento
continuamente aquí se puede ver qué
parte del muro contra inundaciones se
está hundiendo esta pieza y esta pieza
estaban niveladas y ahora tenemos
probablemente alrededor de 5 centímetros
de desplazamiento
Los Huracanes no son la única amenaza
toda la costa de Luisiana también se
enfrenta un aumento del nivel del mar y
expertos adviertan que podría subir 60
centímetros para 2050
Si tuvieras que mirar hacia el agua de
allí verás que hay un montón de árboles
muertos esto una vez fue un bosque de
ciprés
y habría proporcionado un amortiguador
natural para Nueva Orleans de las
tormentas Los huracanes y el agua
para hacer frente a la creciente amenaza
empresarios locales están tratando de
encontrar soluciones esta empresa
recicla vidrio de la ciudad para
convertirlo en Arena con la esperanza de
frenar la erosión de la costa
traemos unas 15 toneladas de vidrio a la
semana todo lo que se tritura cae en un
embudo el material pesado cae
directamente al fondo de esta bolsa de
aquí Este es nuestro principal producto
luego la arena se transfiere a sacos de
tela que se descomponen en seis meses lo
que permite que el nuevo material se
mezcle con el medio ambiente
aquí se han reciclado hasta ahora 1250
toneladas de vidrio
el estado de un campo de fútbol cada 100
minutos no podemos reemplazar eso pero
podemos implementar estratégicamente
nuestro material para frenar la erosión
tres veces por semana los residentes
vienen a dejar sus botellas de vidrio
cuánto impacto tienen 18.000 kilos
depende del escenario si está bien
desplegado 4.500 kilos de arena pueden
cambiar la trayectoria de un pantano
la restauración costera ha sido algo por
lo que peleamos en Luisiana toda mi vida
he discutido al respecto Entonces cuando
lo ves desaparecer de primera mano es
como un shock estos muchachos pelean esa
batalla la forma en que peleo esa
batalla extrayendo más vasos el 8 de
noviembre los votantes de Luisiana y de
todo el país emitirán sus votos si bien
aproximadamente la mitad de ellos dice
que el cambio climático es importante
está muy por detrás de otros temas como
la economía al derecho al aborto o el
crimen